本能は全っていうのは本当に合ってるんですかね。
だってほんの進化しながらできてくるからね。何年経っとる?生物ができてからずっと本能で生きてきたんだ。進化してきたんだ。何年経っ我々を生き延びさしたんだ。どし信者能。これは精神の目的だよ。我々が生きる的だよ。
種族保存なんよ。それがみんな嫌やろ。
自分のためにと思いたいもんね。違うんや
。種族保存で今まで40億年間進化し
ながら種族保存をしてくれたから。今自分
がいるんじゃん。先祖に感謝せにゃなあ。
それをあのバカども古いとか言ってさ、
否定しようとするじゃんなあ。だからダメ
なんだ。もっと感謝の気持ちを持ってな。
こ精一杯生きてちゃんと思孫を残すことが
できるじゃん。で、それが最高の幸福を
生産じゃん。子供を生産生む、子供を
育てる。その前に結婚するとから始まって
子供を生む、子供を育てる。子供が1人前
になる。そのためにお祝いするじゃん。
嬉しってね。あれが最高の幸福なんだ。
個人主義ヨーロッパお得意のあんなもんに
毒されるんじゃない。いざとなったら
我が身を捨てて国のためによ。みんな
今までそうしてくれたから。
今の我々があるんだ。我々もお返しをせね。子孫のためにね。
本能が全だと悪の定義はどうなるんですか?
本能に反するのが悪く。例を上げる。例えばシットという感情がある。嫉妬は同じ試験を受けて自分が
点、自分のライバルが90
点。その時に嫉妬が湧いてくるね。奴のが上だということになって価値があるということやからその嫉妬は怒りやろ。
その怒りというのは立ち向かうという行動
をするわけよ。で、その原因となった数学
のテストやった。その数学に立ち向かうの
さ。で、一生懸命数学の勉強をして次の
試験の時に自分が85点でやが80点だっ
たら自分の方が上になった。目的達成や。
だから嫉妬が綺麗に消える。嫉妬が消えて
やったという幸福になるからね。ところが
大変なやん。一生懸命勉強して楽しい時間
ゲームをちょっと遠慮せないかいいことが
なくなる苦しいことが多くなるだから
もっとデっ取り早く嫉妬を消そうとするん
やたらその自分より上のやつを自分1人で
はとても叶わんもんでみんなで寄ってたっ
て踏ん付けちまう自分たちより下になった
そこで嫉妬が消えてやったになるんやけど
それ数学でやったわけはないんやからね
残るんだいつまでだってもだからそういう
方法はあ、自分が勉強する、自分が進歩
するという方法は全なんだけども、嫉妬は
出来上がった理由があって、その通り本能
通りに使えばええんだが、本能の強い人は
嫉妬を正しく使う。これを食うと言うんや
ぞ。
仏教で言う空というのは本能通りの理性の
ことや。これがもし踏ん付けてみんなで
やっちまってでも嫉妬が消えやり方が悪い
かなってもっとひどくやっつけても
やっぱり嫉妬は消えいつまで経っても嫉妬
が残るやろこの状態をリ廻転うんだ。やっ
てもやっても目的は達成できないそうやね
。やり方が間違っとるからね。数学で勝負
せんといかんのに相手を殴り倒すことで
勝負しようとしてこれは間違いな。だから
それをリ廻転職というリ廻転から逃れない
かんやろ。逃れるためには元に戻って嫉妬
で勉強するんだ。これが嫉妬の正しい使い
方だからな。嫉妬は攻撃、怒りだから。
怒りは攻撃行動。立ち向かうという行動を
するから数学に立ち向かえでどんどん
どんどん進歩していってその次の時にやり
上に行く。次の試験で。だ嫉妬が綺麗に
消える。これがクです。
えっとね、私の言うことは正しいこと
ばっかりだ。だから今からまだ続くから、
えー、正しい人生、死ぬ時に満足の行く
人生、それを送りたけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ。